at this time of the year  christmas lights and lighting chains  like this one  are used to decorate our homes and  brighten the festive atmosphere  but what if they ruin your holiday  instead  the power supply of this lighting shade  for example  is not securely anchored  large parts are easily accessible and  you may receive an electric shock  national authorities and the open  commission  work every day to ensure that the gifts  you choose are safe  and they order to the retailer  the withdrawal of a dangerous product  from the market  the safety get a common european  platform  alerts all the member states about the  presence of dangerous products in the  european union  only this year they have circulated  already more than 1 800 alerts on the  safety gear rapid alert system so  that all member states can take action  and protect consumers in european union  keep your holidays safe  have a look at the safety gear website